aux etats unis la maison blanche indique
faire de la lutte contre la
désinformation autour de la vaccination
contre le coc vide une de ses priorités
pour en parler on retrouve tout de suite
notre correspondant à washington thomas
bonnes et de mauvaises est bon soir
l'administration maiden hausse le ton
contre les plateformes numériques dans
quel but
cela fait plusieurs mois que joe biden
tente de convaincre toujours plus
d'américains de se faire vacciner
beaucoup d'efforts sont déployés par
l'administration de la maison blanche et
la semaine dernière il y avait donc une
conférence de presse à la maison blanche
conférence de presse pour aborder ce
sujet de la lutte contre la
désinformation notamment la
désinformation en ligne selon elle est
donnée de la maison blanche 67% des
américains non vaccinés ont été exposés
au moins une fois à une fausse
information et quelques instants plus
tard joe biden a été interrogé justement
sur le rôle de ces plateformes
numériques dans cette lutte contre la
désinformation écoutez sa réponse et
surtout ces accusations très virulente à
l'égard de facebook concernant la
désinformation autour du coc vide quel
est votre message aux plateformes comme
facebook ils tuent des gens je veux dire
regardez la seule pandémie que nous
avons et parmi les non vaccinés et tuent
des gens
joe biden est revenu sur ses propos
aujourd'hui en atteignant un petit peu
ces accusations expliquant qu'
évidemment facebook ne tue pas
directement des gens mais que d'une
façon ils sont quelque peu responsable
de ce qu'il se passe du fait que
certains américains ne se vaccinent pas
il faut se dire que facebook avait pas
très pas trop apprécié évidemment les
déclarations du locataire de la maison
blanche
la direction de facebook dit avoir mis
en place énormément de ressources pour
justement lutter contre la
désinformation 167 millions distille de
publication ont été supprimés depuis le
début de la pandémie
écoutez cet extrait du communiqué donc
de facebook en réaction aux propos de
joe biden les données montrent que 85 %
des utilisateurs de facebook aux états
unis ont été ou souhaitent être vaccinés
contre le coc vie de 19
l'objectif du président by dunn était de
70 % d'américains vacciner au 4 juillet
facebook n'est pas la raison pour
laquelle cet objectif a été manquée et
thomas la question de l'adhésion des
américains à la vaccination est aussi
source de débat très politique
oui parce que lors de la même conférence
de presse qui a donc eu lieu la semaine
dernière à la maison blanche la porte
parole jen psaki a indiqué que
l'administration de la maison blanche
donc signalait des publications à
facebook ce qui a provoqué une passe
d'armes avec un journaliste de fox news
ce journaliste interrogeant la porte
parole de la maison blanche si c'était
bien le rôle de l'administration byden
en l'occurrence de signaler des
publications à facebook il a fait
référence à big brother évidemment
référence donc au livre 1984 de george
orwell foxnews qui est d'ailleurs est
aussi accusé par certains justement de
proposer de propager une forme
d'hésitation à la vaccination c'est en
tout cas ce que pense anthony fochi vous
le savez il est le conseiller santé de
la maison blanche il a été interrogé ce
week-end sur l'antenne de cnn justement
au sujet de la position donc de foxy
nous écouter le docteur anthony fauci
si nous avions eu le rejet des vaccins
que nous voyons dans certains médias je
ne pense pas qu'il aurait été possible
d' éradiquer la variole
nous aurions probablement toujours la
variole et nous aurions probablement
toujours la polio dans ce pays si nous
avions eu le genre de fausses
informations qui sont répondus
actuellement voilà évidemment qu'une
déclaration qui a provoqué beaucoup de
réactions beaucoup de débats politiques
il faut dire qu'un certain nombre d'élus
d'opposition donc des républicains
estiment que c'est plutôt l'attitude et
la stratégie globale de la maison
blanche qui alimente en quelque sorte
l'hésitation de certains américains à la
vaccination et puis dans ce débat il y à
un acteur qui est intervenu c'est
évidemment l'ancien président des états
unis donald trump qui a publié un
communiqué ces dernières heures en
estimant que si les américains ne se
font pas vacciner c'est parce qu'ils ne
font tout simplement pas confiance à
l'administration de joe boyd
merci beaucoup aux abonnés en direct
depuis et washington